un sujet dans la classe politique parle
si peu que l'islam politique et notre
adversaire et que la laïcité cette
valeur fondamentale conquise de haute
lutte par nos aînés est aujourd'hui
abîmées dans nos hôpitaux dans nos
écoles dans nos territoires avec des
pratiques communautaires de plus en plus
lourde et plus violente et bien nous
nous avons des propositions avec
philippe bas et bruno retailleau avec
christian jacob
avec eric diard nous demandons que dans
la constitution la laïcité devienne une
valeur enfin fondamentale non négociable
il faut rappeler à ceux qui nous
dirigent à ceux qui nous gouvernent que
la laïcité c'est ce qui permet de faire
vivre ensemble ceux qui croient au ciel
et ceux qui n'y croient pas et qu'il est
intolérable que dans des quartiers des
familles s'en aille parce qu'elles sont
juives que des professeurs dans des
écoles ne puisse plus enseigner la shoah
nous sommes aujourd'hui au bout d'une
logique celle de la naïveté d'état et de
la lâcheté des élites
il est temps que sur la laïcité nous
soyons d'une fermeté implacable que nous
dénoncions l'adversaire qui est l'islam
politique pour imposer la valeur de la
république et la valeur